it's been a long time coming nine years
since leaders of South America's 12
countries gathered face to face
host president Lula dasila described it
as an overdue and Urgent encounter to
build a regional block that can
demonstrate strength through Unity
together we have a four trillion dollar
GDP together we are the fifth global
economy we have 450 million consumers
and the biggest and most Diversified
energy potential in the world
Brazil's president outlined 15
initiatives for discussion behind closed
doors including Highway energy and trade
integration and a single South American
currency for Continental Commerce
Brazil favors reactivating unasur the
South American Block he helped create 15
years ago but that most countries
abandoned when the political pendulum in
the region swung from left to right most
agreements in South America most
advances of big issues in South America
they are constantly on a stop and go
movement because when there is
ideological alignment there's
willingness to advance when there isn't
ideological alignment the advance
becomes much slower the presence of
Venezuela's president Nicolas Maduro who
many consider authoritarian became
divisive
streaming his own speech on social media
Uruguay's president minced no words
not all of us here have the same
definition of what is respect for
institutions for human rights and for
democracy
president Lula is also Under Fire as the
head of the Region's largest economy he
is clearly trying to recover the role he
played during his last presidency as
South America's natural leader yet right
now he is being strongly criticized both
here at home and abroad for his
unequivocal support of Nicolas Maduro
but in the end there was consensus on
the need not to exclude anyone and to
focus on what they have in common if
they succeed in laying the groundwork
for Continental integration the biggest
challenge will be to create a block that
can survive the test of time
Lucian human Al Jazeera Brasilia